we get to see single Raquel this season
who is she she came out of fun I think
you're gonna like her yeah okay I'm
really excited because we're so used to
you being next to James and James has
this Dynamic personality that you just
have to kind of control and kind of
mother a little bit so we get to see who
you truly are are you excited about that
are you nervous about that I'm really
excited about it I'm more excited than
nervous if anything because I feel like
it's taken me this long to be able to
step into who I really am as a person
and being single I've been able to
explore just that so I'm so thrilled to
be able to share that with everyone
watching and in a way I feel like
I don't know I take pride in when people
come and approach me and they tell me
that they Inspire them to like you know
go and do things that they normally
wouldn't feel comfortable doing because
they struggle with social anxiety too so
it's rewarding so how was that dealing
with social anxiety and going into this
single life all on camera
um
the best decision for me and oddly
enough that was the most comfortable
I've ever felt on camera at the reunion
so I feel like I was just speaking my
truth
well it's interesting because at the
reunion you drop the bomb the engagement
is off and then was there a conversation
with James since then before the cameras
picked back up what did we miss in
between
um you missed an exchange between
well if you really want to know
um during the pandemic I've been dying
to like oh maybe this is too much but
basically we had an interaction
um he ended up moving out of the
apartment that we were living in
together and moved into the apartment
that I was wanting to move into for a
while
um so that was a shock to me and I was
like all right you do you I guess like
I'm gonna figure out where my next move
is and where I'm gonna live basically
um so that was one interaction and then
the other one was just um
picking up a box of stuff from his new
place and seeing it for the first time
and by this time he already had a new
girlfriend so
that was the two interactions that I had
with him and then you'll see us at our
like very first interaction on camera
which was pretty overwhelming were you
shocked that he brought her onto this
season and now she had to film with her
you have to work with her every day no I
wasn't shocked at all I feel like that's
typical of James I mean if I just
reflecting back on our relationship and
how like he how motivated he was to like
bring me on to this show
um
yeah it didn't surprise me you've had a
really rocky relationship with Lala and
obviously she drops a bomb this season
on you
did it before I guessed you dropped that
bomb were you guys bonding at all since
you were both going through a pretty
devastating breakup
no no
um we already were at the point that
like
actually at this point
um I was open to developing a friendship
with Lala just because we were going
through a similar situation
um
and when she told me this like it was I
was shock to me but then also didn't
surprise me that much either it kind of
explains
why she treated me the way that she
treated me and all during the past few
years
um and
yeah I don't know so clear a few things
up did this happen while you guys were
still dating did it come from a place of
jealousy why is she telling you now
great question
um yeah it happened while we were while
James and I were dating and
um
I don't know why she's coming forward
with this information now but she she
claims that she just wanted to get it
off of her chest but you know I feel
like maybe she just wanted to make me I
don't know what her motive was but it's
like okay after all the these years now
you decide to bring it up it's a little
bit fishy what was the second it's a
little calculated yeah definitely what
was the second part you kind of answered
it but moving on so you are enjoying
this single life and then you ruffled a
little feathers you were the one who
broke the pact did you always have your
eyes set on short okay first of all I
didn't know that there was a pact like
this is not information that I was aware
of
um I've I've always thought that shorts
is really cute I don't think I've ever
seen him like as someone to like
potentially pursue a relationship with
until like James and I were definitely
like way broken up
um
which is interesting like I did not
expect that so so where do you and
shorts stand out
we are really good friends we hang out
and uh he's a great guy is anything
still happening or is that over
um I mean it's not like anything serious
is happening okay so who are I set on
now are we dating
um I'm dating myself
yeah I'm just enjoying this time that I
have being single this is my first time
being single since I've been 21 and I
only have two more years in my 20s left
so I feel like this is a time to just
like
doing